we talked about three pound
uh jelly that uh is able to conceive
of the entirety of uh
the fabric of reality in the universe
and everything and oh
also of its own mortality
what do you think is the meaning of it
all
what's the meaning of life
is a three-pound jelly able to answer
that one
no but i can plagiarize joseph campbell
which is uh which is good enough um
joe joe campbell says that you know i
don't think what we're looking for is a
meaning of life
i think what we're looking for is an
experience
of being alive
so that the experiences we have on the
purely physical plane will have
resonances within that are those of our
innermost being and reality you talked
about the true reality absolute truth
um these are all constructs and and i
think they're they're constructs that
that are made day by day and acquire
this aura of factuality remembering
clifford geertz's definition of religion
we're all just
faking it until we make it and i think a
lot of that has to do with moods and
motivations and feelings and emotions
which is not to discredit facts and
figures
but i think that meaning meaning making
is a a very subjective process that is
not only difficult to talk about but
difficult to quantify and experience is
a primary in that versus
so like the actual subjective experience
is primary to
the meaning making process versus like
some kind of rigorous analysis of
like uh having an algorithm that runs
and computes and then finally spits out
42.
well this this is how families are
created um tell me more about well my
wife and i fell in love and made babies
we didn't we didn't type up an excel
sheet and figure out the best way to go
about this that's what i've been doing
all these years that's why i'm single
[Laughter]
too many excel sheets
uh what we say falling in love right we
say fall in love what does that mean to
fall in love you are surrendering
to an intelligence
um that that that is beyond us um you
could say a god-like intelligence
richard rohr the franciscan friar i
mentioned in the universal christ he
writes a lot about how
the divine for you is is often
encountered in the other in fact how
could it be otherwise this is this is
bedrock sacramental theology that you
find
the god in the things in your life as
well you should that that's the proving
ground
for
identifying as god
rather than creating a relationship with
god and so i think that these irrational
states that play a big role in that
irrational well i don't think there's a
better way to end it than on the topic
of love brian thank you so much for a
brilliant exposition of history
and the poetry
i really appreciate you uh talking with
me today i love you alex
i love you too
you